I think that the investor frame is
simply people who have been scored and
Quantified on their ability to make
decisions and so I think that we can
learn a ton from how investors make
decisions overall it's like why Ray
dalio's book principles became like a
bestseller even though 99.9 of people
reading the book aren't even investors
but the principles of good decision
making are just Quantified and we have a
scoreboard for these guys being
excellent decision makers whereas most
other people you don't have a real
scoreboard so we can't tell how valid is
their advice and I think that's what
makes uh taking advice from really
world-class investors who've been doing
it for decades as a great source of
information because we can validate that
they have a stack of undeniable proof
that they are who they say they are